I really wanted to give you an
opportunity to clarify who your best
friends are I know this has been I'm
gonna get contractual boner rap who my
best friends are you know I'm gonna
plead the fifth this I where was this
oh the wire did yeah I did a wire
interview they asked me who my best
friends were I said I said three of my
friends I should look I should have
listed all 25 that's my fault because
they all individually got back to me and
texting me and were like yo what the
hell's going on so I'm so no I'm not
gonna say any names vlog squad just as a
whole they all make the less you are
with some best friends it's a little bit
about how the vlog squad really came to
because you guys are you know I know you
hate the blog squad name but now it's
just two iconic to ever know yeah now we
have no choice
yeah how it came to be I mean we all we
all kind of ran into each other from
vine we all started on the vine app and
yeah that was a blast we just made
videos together and it was so casual cuz
it all started out with just me filming
everybody so like everyone was always on
board because like no one else was
vlogging so isn't like getting in the
way of things and I don't know it was a
little just us hanging out it was it's
so casual and like that's why that's why
everything works is because we're
literally a genuine group of friends so
it makes everything so much easier but
has a dynamic change at all cuz now you
guys are growing that everyone's moving
out saying is what remodeling his whole
house so everyone's doing really adult
things talking about remodeling his
house he has it his eyes room with the
crap no yeah everyone's everyone's doing
their own the dynamic has changed a bit
just cuz we're like all doing alright
but I'm at least trying to but no for
the most part still there we see each
other less I would say that for sure
because we literally all live in
different homes and at one point
everyone used to live in one so yeah but
it's still it's a pretty solid speaking
out I feel like now is a good time to
kind of adjust some vlog squad gossip
just rapid-fire style let's just gonna
hit it with you it
first will you actually vlog from the
delivery room when Josh's baby is born
this is this is still in discussion
possibly probably all right probably not
no the answer's no all right this is a
big one do you think Trisha Trisha and
Jason will ever get married I think so I
think there's gonna be a slow day of
vlogging and I think it's gonna happen I
think one day I'm gonna be like I have
nothing please help me out and she's
gonna get down on one knee for me cuz
he's my he's my buddy
what a friend yeah my best friend now
well now testing your friendship
have you listened to chicken parmesan
and heartbreak what haven't I haven't no
I've listened to like no I was there
when they were recording it I haven't
gotten to listen to like the entire
album yeah is it great hey it's Trisha
Paytas of course it's right this is an
iconic pop star no but they're shooting
a music video on Friday so I'm gonna be
there and yeah now have to catch up will
you be attending Erin's wedding I hope I
don't know if she invites me and you're
the one person left out of the list
I mean here's the thing if I'm going I
have to film that yeah so maybe she
won't
I think that's someone yeah yeah as long
as David's not like I'm gonna bring a
snake to the wedding like if David's
gonna surprise me with Harry Styles
performing at the wedding then like film
all you want Vince Jonas family ever
gonna get their own Netflix show
possibly we're working on we're working
on something for them maybe I don't even
tell them anything so it's all secret
just one day all of a sudden accrual
will just show up in their house maybe
quite possibly they won't even think
anything is the first episode of our
show
Scotty in your vlogs born he broke his
leg and he stole it doesn't guess you've
all been asking for it for the next
seven days oh man I'm gonna be in your
vlog hell no what do you think about a
crane is new boyfriend huh I bear
Erin and Carly said that she's dating
someone from
oh yeah I don't I don't know what's
going on they are impaired the most
confusing time in Carina yeah are the
most confusing pair so I would not know
for dating anybody or whatever they're
doing what does it take to join the
blocks why I feel like you guys pretty
much you don't really need any new
members at this point it's a little
little big no that's the thing though
the way I think of it is like it's like
an app updating so like like you think
you don't need anything else and you
think the app is perfect but like then
Twitter will sneak up an update and
you're black I hate this I hate this new
person but you need it to stay engaged
with the app Twitter and I think that's
what like our group is is like I'm so
welcoming to new people coming and going
or whatever because it's like it's the
new faces are always great and it's like
maybe people don't realize that they
need a fresh face to keep being
entertained by the videos but I think
they do
and just like like I said just like when
you hate a Twitter update you just you
end up getting used to it in two weeks
so it's kind of same thing my friends
are like a Twitter update
[Music]